[music]
[singing]
I'm unaffected. Why would you try
[music] to ever put me second? You're
just another groupy to me. No, [music]
I'm out here single and I need something
real. Now I got give a how you
[music] feel. I'm out here single. Tell
me what's the deal. Now I got sters.
Give [music] a
No bros. No new man. [music]
No bro boys. No new
[music]
bro new.
No bro. No new friends. [music] I'm that
give me my sense. Ain't no loud. Ain't
no shade. call me. You know he say
look so good makes no sense. Bad ass. My
bad ass friends. [music] No broke boys
in no sh
[music]
new.
No boy, no new friend.
No broke boys, no new friends. No, no,
[music] no, no.
I'm that you give me my 10. Ain't no
lie, [music] ain't no shade. me,
you know he paid. No good, makes no
sense. [music] Bad ass My bad ass
friend. No boys, ain't no shade.
[music] you know he broke boys, no new
friends.
No [music] boys, no new friends.
No boys, no
[music]
dis.
>> No broke boys, [music] no new friend.
I'm
a no, ain't no sh you know he looks no
[music] good makes no sense. Better
boy. [music]
[music]
Heat.
No, [music] no, no.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Hey friends, thanks for watching that
awesome flow session. I hope you enjoyed
it as much as I enjoyed making it. Uh,
real quick, if you dug those Orb LED
contact po that I was using in this
video, you can get a discount on them,
10% off when you use the promo code
drexfactor with a zero instead of an O
at checkout over at ultraoy.com.
Once again, that is drexfactor with a
zero instead of an O. Go check that out.
Uh, I'll include a link down in the
description. Thank you so much to
Ultraoy for sponsoring this video and
giving me a reason to go out and flow
every month. Y'all rock. And speaking of
thank yous, uh, thanks are owed to the
friends of the channel. Big thanks to
Dark Monk, Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow
Toys, Pyroer Light Toys, and Ultraoy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible. You can learn more
about all of these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video. And finally,
this video would not exist were it not
for my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you. You all
rock. If you enjoy these videos and
you'd like to get your name in the
credits or access to a host of other
awesome rewards, you can do that by
checking out my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo
and signing up. Even better, you'll be
helping me out on my mission to bring po
spinning and flow to the whole wide
world. So, go check that out, please.
And thank you. And if you'd like to
check out other flow sessions I've done
like this one, I'll go ahead and include
a link to a playlist to those videos
down in the description as well as up
here on [music] screen. Thanks so much
for watching. Make sure you get out and
flow today. And if you live in the
United States, happy holidays. I will
see you with a new video real soon. Take
care now. [music] Peace.